Companies can be large or small.
They can be in different fields,
manufacturing, agriculture,
transportation, education, finance.
No two companies are the same, but
there are a couple of things that
can be said about any company.
First, every company has customers
with a problem to be solved.
Even animal shelters and
government agencies have customers.
Maybe you work on a team that works
only with internal customers,
other company teams.
Second, companies solve problems by
providing some kind of product or
service.
A cosmetics company makes hair products
to solve the problem of bed hair.
A beverage company makes an energy
drink to combat tiredness.
An education company creates online
courses to close the skills gap.
A tech company creates a game engine for
mobile games to eliminate boredom.
Companies identify problems,
come up with solutions,
implement their ideas and
then deliver products to customers.
So you can think of it as a cycle that
starts and ends with the customer.
The challenge is to build a high
quality, cost effective and reliable
solution that you can put in the hands
of your customer as soon as possible.
It's important to be in alignment
on your overall company goal.
When development teams are rewarded for
launching new features quickly but
operations is rewarded for
keeping things stable, you have
the potential for conflict across teams.
When you realize that the real goal
is to deliver good service to your
customers, teams are more likely to
work together to find a solution.
To do this,
you have to understand your customers.
Are you working for external or
internal customers?
If you're a part of
a large organization,
who are the internal
people who use your work?
What is the main problem that your
company or division is trying to solve?